bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur sociaux logos dans cette vidéo nous
allons parler de la prise dans une
perspective sociologique nous allons
essayer voilà de comprendre ce que
représente la prison et de manière plus
large le système carcéral dans notre
société
comment la prison a été
institutionnalisée comment elle a été
pensée par qui pour qui et pour quoi on
va se demander également quelles sont
les limites que présente le système
carcéral actuelle et on va finalement se
poser dans l'agression de est ce que
c'est le seul modèle possible pour se
faire dans un premier temps je vous
présentais un petit peu la prison dans
sa dimension culturelle et sociale avant
de vous en expliquer les limites
et puis dans une troisième partie on va
cette demande est question des
alternatives au système carcéral telle
qu'on connaît alors pour commencer je
donc vous présenter la dimension
culturelle et sociale de la prison alors
déjà dans cette vidéo je vais de la
prison et de manière plus large fait du
système carcéral c'est à dire de quand
on porte plainte jusqu'à
l'emprisonnement et la réinsertion en
passant par le tribunal et s'est donc on
va pas seulement de l'emprisonnement
mais de tout le système qu'il va autour
de la prison et qui s'organise pour
pénaliser les crimes s'appelle donc la
justice pénale
alors si on va un peu d'écouté de la
sociologie ce que nous disent les
sociologues qui ont réfléchi à la
question c'est déjà que la prison si une
institution récente la prison a été
institutionnalisée entre le 18è et le
19è siècle michel foucault nous explique
que la prison est une proposition
humaniste par opposition à la peine de
mort et à la torture qui était alors en
vigueur pour punir les crimes en fait la
prison elle elle repose sur la l'idée
qu'il faut croire au changement et à la
possibilité d'une réinsertion après
avoir voilà
était puni pour un crime donc voilà pour
très rapidement l'histoire de la prison
et du système carcéral
mais à 2-0 à se poser c mais en fait à
quoi ça sert la prison le système
carcéral dans sa globalité serre selon
mme chua deux choses alors michel
foucault a écrit un livre qui s'appelle
surveiller et punir et comme son nom
l'indiqué est bien sûr michel foucault
il y à deux dimensions utilitaire à la
prison la première ça va être de
surveiller les individus donc des
individus qui pourraient nuire à la
société en fait des envieux qui pourrait
passer à l'acte criminel est la deuxième
dimension qu'il met en lumière c'est
celle de punir le crime et non de punir
les criminels mais j avoue qu on décrit
surtout la prison et le système carcéral
en tant qu'institution en fait en
sciences sociales
on estime qu'une institution relève d'un
état et donc qu'elles relèvent également
d'une idéologie
donc je vous qu'on va nous expliquer que
si la prison est montré comme une
manière de protéger la société
c'est avant tout des institutions qui
permet de protéger l'état et pour
protéger l'état la prison en fait met en
avant la discipline selon lui la
discipline c'est en fait le contrôle des
corps et donc d'en surveiller punir il
explique que la prison permet d'avoir un
contrôle un peu particulier des corps il
va d'abord y avoir le contrôle dans
l'espace donc le contrôle des corps dans
l'espace c'est à dire grâce à
l'emprisonnement la restriction des
libertés de mouvement même avec les
assignations à résidence allait brasser
les chroniques ce genre de choses mais
il va aussi me dire qu'il ya un contrôle
des corps dans le temps en fait selon
lui le système carcéral va impacter les
gens bien au-delà de la simple détention
donc de la personne emprisonnée puisque
savoir bac tu es déjà le détenu dans le
temps long c'est à dire que bien après
sa réinsertion il va éprouver donc déjà
des difficultés à sortir de prison à se
réinsérer dans la société
peut-être qu'il va cette personne ce
détenu va vivre avec des traumatismes
qui vont l'accompagner pour le reste de
sa vie
on sait également
de très nombreuses études qui ont prouvé
que les personnes qui ont été
emprisonnés en plus de chance de
repasser à l'acte par la suite vers un
taux de récidive plus élevé chez les
gens qui sont passés par la case prison
et michel foucault va aussi nous dire
que sa marque plus largement la société
avait quand même d'aider d'un exemple
puisque si on a une personne que l'on
connaît dans notre entourage qui est
passé par la case prison et bien on va
avoir peur de se retrouver dans la même
situation est donc s'autocontrôler veux
penser à l' ouvrage pour elle tout dans
lequel bueno la ricordeau met en avant
le fait que la prison ne touche pas
seulement les détenus mais également
tout l'entourage c'est jallet proches de
prisonniers les proches de détenus et
notamment les femmes qui sont
proportionnellement moins emprisonnée
que les hommes notamment en france parce
que elle se retrouve en fait avec toute
la charge du foyer delà du lien social à
maintenir mais aussi de la charge
économique d'avoir une personne qui est
en prison qui n'apporte plus rien
financièrement à l' équilibre familial
etc
donc voilà ça impacte et au final une
population beaucoup plus large que la
seule population des détenus et selon
michel foucault si on combine en fait
sur contrôle des corps dans l'espace et
ses contrôles des corps dans le temps eh
bien on arrive à en fait une masse de
corps docile qui ont été disciplinés par
l'état et donc selon lui le la prison et
le système carcéral
quand elles présentent des déséquilibres
permet aux états de gouverner sans
opposition c'est quelque chose qu'on
voit aujourd'hui dans de très nombreux
pays dans le monde et même au final dans
nos démocraties occidentales en bien il
y a des limites quand je vais vous
exposer tous types
donc je vais vous présenter les limites
du système carcéral
la première limite que je vous mettre en
avant c'est celle qui est défendue par
de très nombreux sociologues c'est
l'idée que la définition du crime et une
définition mouvante
alors qu'est ce que je veux dire par là
en fait le mot crime c'est un peu comme
le mot terrorisme c'est des mots qui
font peur mais
c'est pas vraiment quelle réalité lisant
globe et surtout ils ne veulent pas dire
la même chose en fonction des états des
peuples d époque etc
par exemple quand nous en tant que
français on va nous parler de
terroristes on va tout de suite pensé au
djihadisme alors que en turquie le mot
terroriste est utilisé pour désigner les
séparatistes kurdes par exemple donc
voilà ça recouvre des mots terrorisme
recouvre des réalités assez différente
et le mot crime encore plus en fait le
problème central du questionnement sur
ce qu'est ce qu'est la prison est ce qu
est le seul carcérale c'est qu'est-ce
que le crime donc actuellement le crime
dans notre société française
à l'heure où je parle en 2021 les crimes
auxquels on va penser le plus facilement
ça va être par exemple le vol le meurtre
la pédocriminalité voilà ce genre de
choses mais dans d'autres états et dans
d'autres époques les crimes ça aussi été
au seo également d'être homosexuel
d'avorter être un opposant politique
voilà ce genre de choses ça existe aussi
et c'est reconnu en tant que crime vous
l'aurez compris le premier point c'est
l'idée que comme le crie ma définition
mouvante et bien c'est pas forcément si
évident de condamner des gens à être
enfermés pour un crime qu'ils ont commis
deuxième point qu'on pourrait aborder
dans les limites du système carcéral
c'est l'idée qu'on n'est pas forcément
tous égaux face à la loi
alors attention là je vais un peu
ébranlé les grandes idées républicaines
universaliste mais le grand principe
républicain qui veut que chaque homme et
chaque femme soit égal face à la loi est
bien dans les faits n'est pas vraiment
là en fait on a du coup une notion de
crime qui est fixé dans la loi d'un code
pénal mais on a aussi la question de
l'adaptation de la notion de crime au à
l'acte qui a été commis là d'ailleurs
tout le rôle du juge c'est à dire de
réussir à appliquer la loi en fonction
du contexte dans lequel a été commis le
crime
par exemple tu es un homme est interdit
par la loi si je suis un militaire je
vais avoir une perte nette alourdie
puisque je tue quelqu'un qui représente
l'état
par contre si je tue un nazi à l'époque
où un djihadiste aujourd'hui eh bien je
vais percer comme une héroïne et je vais
sûrement ne pas être condamné
hier donc c'est ça qu'on entend par
adaptation d'appel évidemment la france
l'exemple d'un petit peu grossier
adapter la peine au contexte c'est
évidemment essentiel et c'est une grande
force de notre système judiciaire actuel
pour autant le grand problème qu'il ya
quand on veut condamner une personne
c'est qu'il ya non seulement le contexte
immédiat du crime mais également un
contexte social j'ai le même soucieux
économiques à prendre en compte en plus
de tous les présupposés qui peuvent
entourer l'identité de la personne qui a
commis le crime
un exemple dans notre société actuelle
la consommation et la détention de
drogue est interdite et criminaliser ça
veut dire qu'elle est considérée comme
un cri ou autant cg de personnes qui
dans l'âme est dans la même situation
ont été prises en flagrante détention et
consommation de drogue mais que ces deux
personnes sont d'un côté une femme d'une
cinquantaine d'année blanche qui vit
dans le 16e arrondissement de paris
versus un jeune de banlieue noirs ou
maghrébins et bien souvent il y en a un
des deux qui va être condamné beaucoup
plus facilement que l'autre quoi parce
que tout simplement toute la chaîne qui
mène à la au placement en détention est
bien est constituée d'êtres humains ou
tout simplement qui ont un pouvoir sur
sa décision et qu'ils ont des
présupposés sur les personnes qu'elles
vont s'affronter à condamner donc
souvent la femme blanche ira peut-être
jusqu'au commissariat quand le jeune de
banlieue pour aller jusqu'en prison et
là on a donc le fait qu'on n'ait pas
égales face à la loi ensuite le
troisième point que je voudrais aborder
dans les limites du système carcéral
c'est le constat qu'il ya une population
carcérale qui est finalement très peu
hétérogène
alors qu'est ce que je veux dire par là
les études démographiques de la
population carcérale le montre sans
équivoque la population carcérale à
l'échelle internationale
par ailleurs c'est pas seulement une
exception française sont constitués
majoritairement d'hommes et d'hommes
issus de minorités que ce soit des
minorités raciales sexuelles et c'est
donc le pont comment à travers le monde
sait que on a des hommes qui sont on va
dire subalternes comme on pourrait dire
en sociologie qui se retrouve en prison
ainsi aux états unis on va avoir des
hommes
latino qui sont largement surreprésentés
dans la population carcérale comme en
france on va avoir essentiellement des
personnes issues de l'immigration
tout comme au maghreb on va voir
beaucoup de personnes lgbt plus et au
canada ou en australie on va voir
beaucoup de personnes qui sont issus des
natifs amérindiens relatifs à des
indigènes
tout ça ça pose question est en fait
s'inscrit dans l'idée que finalement le
système carcéral est reproduit et il
reste à s'appuyer sur des rapports de
domination existant en fait qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire face à ça quand on voit
que il ya une minorité de la population
qui est sur représentée dans la
population carcérale est ce que c'est
parce que ces personnes là sont plus à
même de commettre un crime
dans ce cas bas qu'est ce qu'on fait
pour qu'elle ne commette pas autant cris
ou alors est ce que on définit le crime
pour que ces personnes se retrouvent à
les commettre facilement il a tout nié
deux sociologues qui ont contribué à
aider qu'il ya une criminalisation des
minorités et ça dépend évidemment des
contextes ra mais comme la prison est
une institution qui relèvent de
l'idéologie de l'état
eh bien l'état va chercher en
définissant le crime a accru miser
davantage les minorités qui pourrait
remettre en cause la sécurité de l'état
alors il a évidemment beaucoup d'autres
problèmes avec le système carcéral que
je pourrais mettre en avant je pense que
du point de vue sociologique seller
peut-être les plus intéressants mais on
pourrait évidemment parler de la
surpopulation carcérale qui montre bien
qu'au final on ne résout pas le problème
parce que si on a de plus en plus de
monde en prison c'est que la prison
n'est pas la solution au problème de
pourquoi est ce que les gens commettent
des crimes mais il ya également les
problèmes par exemple sur l'accès à la
santé notamment pour les femmes détenues
puisque voilà c'est des personnes qui se
retrouvent en fait exclu aussi de tout
le système de santé de protection auquel
tout être humain est censé avoir droit
dans une démocratie il ya également la
question du travail en prison c'est
quelque chose qui est présent un petit
peu en france beaucoup plus aux états
unis en fait les prisonniers participent
à la production voilà deux d'objets qui
vont être vendus et cetera mais
représentent une main d'oeuvre qui est
un peu du pain bénit puisque c'est une
main d'oeuvre qui n'a pas de salaire
donc selon une espèce d'indemnités qui
ne respectent pas du tout du minimum
horaire pour un travail plus des gens
qui ne sont pas syndiqués qui n'ont pas
accès au chômage à la protection sociale
et cetera
donc voilà et encore plein d'autres
problèmes mais ça pourrait faire l'objet
d'autres vidéos
du coup on va passer à la troisième
partie de cette vidéo qui est bien face
à tous ces problèmes que faire quelles
sont les alternatives possibles au
système carcéral d'alcon connais
aujourd'hui par tous les arguments que
j'ai mis en avant jusqu'ici se retrouve
dans la rhétorique des défenseurs de
l'abolitionnisme alors je sais que ça
peut faire peur un diplôme aux
abolitionnistes fed est d'avoir une
posture abolitionniste face à la prison
c'est le fait de penser tout simplement
qu on pourrait vivre dans un monde sans
prison alors c'est un peu surprenant
quand on entend comme ça et on attend sa
table sur la défensive en mode c'est à
dire que des criminels vont courir les
rues etc
mais en fait c'est un peu plus compliqué
que la voiture abolitionniste en fait ce
la plupart du temps en tout cas n'est
pas dans l'idée qu'il faut là maintenant
tout de suite arrêter totalement
d'utiliser les prisons mais plutôt
défend l'idée qu'on pouvait faire mieux
si on faisait différemment
en gros ce serait les une transition
vers un autre système judiciaire pour en
fait passer d'une justice pénale à une
justice sociale
je m'explique la poussière à bout du
sinistre c'est une idée qu'il faut
reconnaître et traiter les crimes en
tant que crime structurelle et non pas
en tant que crime individuel tu en
prends l'exemple des violences faites
aux femmes
c'est l'idée qui ne sert à rien de
condamner un violeur puis un ovule
heures puis un autre violeur quand ils
sont condamnés
bref mais qu'il faut plutôt lutter avec
tous les moyens possibles au niveau de
l'éducation des institutions qui sera
contre la culture du viol pour les
abolitionnistes en fait l'idée de
condamner les criminels c'est vraiment
pour eux une posture à court terme alors
que l'idée de vouloir lutter contre la
dimension structurelle du crime a des
impacts beaucoup plus qu'ils vont
prendre plus de temps à mettre en place
mais qui auront des impacts beaucoup
plus profond et qui engageront un vrai
changement dans notre société
en fait en soit on condamne certains
violeurs en disant que pour l'exemple
les autres en face vont être
impressionnés ne vont pas le refaire
versus une posture on se dit qu'on va
lutter contre la culture de viol qui
produit les violeurs et quand même si on
arrête de produire les violeurs et bien
on arrêtera de mettre des villes en
prison puisqu'il n'y en aura plus en
fait de manière générale
l'abolitionnisme se fonde sur l'idée que
tout recours à la justice pénale doit
d'être perçue comme un échec du
collectif un échec que vous faites de la
société et dont un échec de l'état à
protéger associer des crimes il ya
beaucoup d'arguments terre différents au
sein même de cette perspective
abolitionniste voudrais vous présenter
un petit peu plus en détail aujourd'hui
la perspective afro féministe et un peu
les origines de la posture
abolitionnistes pour ce faire je vais
devoir convoquer une
intellectuel qui est un peu une figure
phare de la posture abolitionniste en la
personne de angela davis à angela davis
c'est une intellectuelle et militante
afro féministes américaines
il ya donc écrit un livre majeur qui
donne d'ailleurs le nom à cette vidéo
c'est la prison et elle est obsolète
angela davis est là elle s'est
développée politiquement on va dire avec
le civil rights aux états unis dans les
années 70 qui est donc pour une plus
grande indépendance et justice envers
donc les les personnes noires
elle a d'ailleurs elle-même été condamné
à mort en 1971 avant d'être innocenté et
ses combats premier contre la prison
s'inscrivent dans un contexte un peu
particulier on a les premières grandes
révoltes de prisonniers aux états unis
donc à la prison d'atika en 1971 par
exemple en fait tout ce mouvement
qu'elle incarne s'est forgé au moment de
constater et bien qu' il y a vraiment
une sur représentation des noirs
notamment des hommes noirs en prison et
que bah c'est pas normal
il ya quelque chose qui cloche en fait
selon angela davis le système carcéral
en tant qu'institution et l'entretien
des rapports sociaux de pouvoir des
rapports sociaux de domination donc des
blancs sur les noirs des hommes sur les
femmes des aussi des hétérosexuels et
homosexuels etc et s appuie notamment
dans son cas sur le fait que les hommes
et les femmes noires sont
particulièrement exposées à
l'emprisonnement et qu'il y a même si
loin une volonté de l'état d'emprisonner
les hommes noirs pour
les empêcher de se former en tant que
groupe politique
en fait d'exister en tant que groupe
subversif face à l'état il ya même eu
toute une campagne officiellement de
lutte contre la drogue qui a contribué
largement à l'emprisonnement de très
nombreuses personnes noires qui souvent
en plus était innocent je vous conseille
d'ailleurs à ce sujet un documentaire
netflix que le fond mais en barre
d'infos mais voilà un petit peu le
contexte dans lequel s'inscrit
d'ailleurs en jade avis ça va même faire
un parallèle qui est assez intéressant
elle va convoquer foucault qu'on avait
évoqué tout à l'heure puisqu'elle va le
dire qu'en fait les hommes qui se
considéraient comme des viandes donc les
hommes noirs à ce moment là les hommes
qui sont considérés comme déviants vont
être construits comme des criminels tout
comme les femmes déviante
il ya quelques siècles ont été
construites comme hystérique comme folle
voire même encore par le passé comme
sorcière et tout ça c'est pour en fait
accroître le contrôle de l'état sur des
corps et des individus qui sont
considérés comme déviants comme
marginaux qui pourrait menacer
l'intégrité de l'état
en fait c'est pour ça que selon elle
c'est essentiel d'avoir une perspective
féministe et antiraciste sur le système
carcéral pour en revenir au niveau plus
général angelis va tout simplement nous
dire qu'il faut remettre en cause le
système carcéral à voir si le moment on
a une accumulation du nombre de détenus
aux états unis et notamment du nom de
détenus qui sont condamnés à des peines
à perpétuité
là elle met en avant le fait que la
population nord américaine représente 5
% de la population mondiale et que
pourtant un prisonnier sur quatre dans
le monde est en prison aux états unis
donc on a 25 % de la population
carcérale aux etats unis ce qui pourrait
est ainsi de l'échec total du système
carcéral américain à résoudre en fait la
question du crime parce que défend déjà
dévissé que le système carcéral tel
qu'il existe aujourd'hui nous décharge
en tant que société de la responsabilité
à nous engager sérieusement résoudre les
problèmes de société qui
mène ensuite au passage à l'acte et au
crime donc pour l on devrait lutter avec
autant de vigueur contre la peine
capitale que contre les peines
d'emprisonnement à perpétuité
car pour elle en fait c'est la même
chose avec différents le tout la posture
abolitionniste au delà danger à davis
repose sur vraiment l'idée que la prison
n'est pas une solution au fait de
réduire le nombre de crimes mais qu'il
faudrait plutôt mettre en place et un
continuum de solutions pour empêcher
d'en arriver en fête au stade de
l'emprisonnement et donc si on suit la
logique qu'ils ont remplacés au fur et à
mesure la justice pénale par une justice
sociale en réduire le nombre de
personnes en prison et on arriverait à
une société moins criminel donc voilà
pour le moment c'est un sujet
extrêmement large sur lequel il y a
beaucoup de choses à dire
j'espère que cette vidéo vous aurez un
peu permis déjà de remettre en question
l'existence de la prison en tant que
système qui nous permet de lutter contre
les crimes et de voir un petit peu les
différentes postures sociologique il ya
face à au système carcéral
voilà pour l'heure je m'arrête ici
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu
c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à laisser un
gem à vous abonner à la chaîne à
partager sur vos réseaux a fait revivre
sociaux logos et puis je vous retrouve
très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo
[Musique]